eu passei um período na minha vida que
eu cheguei a pesar 100 quilos
então eu não deixei essa peteca cair eu
descobri o que eu tinha que fazer para
me ajudar e ajudar os outros
então na minha frente o que a gente tem
que prestar atenção hoje em dia a
tecnologia tem nos ajudado muito na
verdade o que a gente percebe que a
gente tem carros que andam sozinhos o
celular corrigir as nossas mensagens que
nem sempre isso é bom
outro dia mandei uma mensagem para uma
paciente nem eu falei então te logo sua
fofa e o corretor transcreveu gordhan
então muito cuidado com isso porque nem
sempre essa desgraça pode nos ajudar né
até explicar que focinho de porco não
era tomada
demorou muito né pois é é e então a
ciência tem nos ajudado carros andando
sozinho a gente tem por exemplo nano
robozinhos que vão levar limpar nossa
casa na verdade robozinhos em relação à
medicina isso também tem acelerado né a
evolução que a gente percebe máquina
super potência podendo avaliar nossa
saúde máquina super potentes avaliando a
presença ou não de câncer não é verdade
em relação à nutrição e se eu dissesse
pra vocês que através da sua saliva eu
posso detectar quais são os alimentos
que fazem bem e os alimentos que não lhe
fazem bem
esse exame você colega coleta com escova
minha a sua saliva e você pode verificar
a sua o seu dna o que você do do papai e
da mamãe que eu infelizmente em alguns
aspectos eu herdei todos urgência da
obesidade
então pra emagrecer minha gente vocês
não têm noção eu ralo
halo duro tenho que comer pouco e fazer
muito exercício alguns familiares meus
que estão aqui sabem que isso é verdade
então o que cabe dentro desse exame
ele avalia primeiro qual é a sua
capacidade de metabolizar carboidratos
proteínas e gorduras
ele consegue enxergar se você tem
facilidade de emagrecer ou não a minha
deu péssima eu tenho dificuldade em
emagrecer é em relação à facilidade de
ganhar peso se você come um
brigadeirinho fora o meu deu 100%
quer dizer em alguns casos a pessoa não
é gorda porque ela quer é porque ela
gosta de comer e urgentes dela coitada
aumentam duas vezes a capacidade deve
engordar
tá certo pois é isso infelizmente isso
pode acontecer é que mais que o exame
mostra seu exercício tem ação na sua
vida ou não e se você come por
influências e emocionais
então se você tá cristinho você come se
você está com raiva você come inclusive
geneticamente falando você pode observar
isso que mais que o exame mostra qual é
a sua absorção de vitaminas se você
absorve a vitamina a e b2 b6 b9 b12 abc7
a vitamina d
aquela do sol a vitamina é e cálcio e
magnésio também acreditem se quiser
mulheres que tomam cálcio em excesso
podem petrificar suas artérias que a
mulher vive querendo tomar cálcio nem
para todos isso é bom tá certo que mais
o exame ver intolerâncias alimentares
você pode observar se você tem
intolerância à álcool café a glúten a
sodium e se você é sensível ao glúten
não tendo genda doença celíaca porque
hoje virou moda tirar glúten e tirar
lactose
nem todas as pessoas precisam retirar
tudo isso inclusive um alerta
você não precisa tirar
tudo sem detectar que você intolerante
am e o que isso tem a ver minha gente
com a real função da nutrição tudo né
porque porque a gente vai verificar qual
é o combustível que te leva para a vida
eu digo assim existem pessoas que
nasceram com o carro a gasolina que tão
abastecendo com álcool principalmente
ontem à noite né brincadeiras à parte
aqui
bom isso pode lhe trazer uma dificuldade
de viver
eu tenho alguns exemplos de algumas
pacientes que fizeram o exame
bom chega uma paciente muito triste
vocês não têm noção às vezes como as
pessoas chegam no consultório ela
dizendo assim doutora meu casamento está
acabado porque eu sou uma pessoa que tem
um boi na barriga que não vai embora
nunca tenha um sapo achando a barriga
vive cheio de fatos o tempo inteiro tem
eructações então eu ando eu pareço uma
coisa esquisita itou obesa quando a
gente realizou exames nesta paciente ela
tinha quase todas as intolerâncias tinha
intolerância sódio ou seja ela inchava
muito te intolerância a glúten ou seja
muita flatulência e tinha a aas ódio
também eu falei só de cafeína glúten e
lactose veja bem 4 intolerâncias o que
levava essa pessoa não ter uma vida
normal a digestibilidade alimentar dela
era muito ruim conclusão depois da de
ter recebido o exame e ter feito a dieta
é porque não adianta nada você a
nutricionista pegar um exame pegar uma
dieta e não praticar a mesma coisa que
nada e ela praticou ela emagreceu 17
quilos está linda e maravilhosa
realmente a foto do antes e depois
quando ela me mostra eu digo parecia sua
mãe antes e hoje a filha
de tão linda que ela ficou e ganhou um
novo casamento eu acho que essa foi uma
das melhores partes na verdade o marido
não preciso dizer que foi o próximo
paciente é bom
uma outra uma outra paciente ela tem ela
é gaúcha e vivia se escorando pelas
paredes
ela tinha muitas tonturas já estava indo
pra médico nos estados unidos que não
sabia o que estava acontecendo com ela
culturas muito forte inclusive quando
ela chegou no consultório ela chegou
chorando e quase desmaiando
fizemos um exame nela ela tinha
simplesmente gente intolerância cafeína
foi retirado então o chimarrão dela e
ela hoje está ótima
super tranquila parece brincadeira mas é
um pontinho muito importante na vida da
gente esse é um dos casos o meu também é
quando eu fiz né o meu próprio exame
eu emagreci mais cinco quilos dos que eu
já tinha emagrecido antes ou seja o que
aconteceu eu tive uma noção muito maior
porque quando um jovem fala pra você não
é uma pessoa lhe dizendo é um gente
dizendo você não tem contas contestação
na verdade não pode contestar a dieta
ela também pode ajudar uma pessoa a ter
uma boa performance profissional
então se você é um executivo que precisa
de decisões rápidas ou se você precisa
de muita criatividade você trabalha no
marketing
acredite se quiser a sua alimentação faz
sim total diferença na sua vida eu digo
se você tá nasceu com o carro a gasolina
e tá abastecendo com álcool
você está andando capenga o seu motor
vai começar a pipocar
imagina o triatleta que está usando o
combustível errado não precisa ir tão
longe
nós mesmos né você pode estar se
sentindo com gases pode estar se
sentindo sem de gestão direito pode ter
certeza é algum alimento que você
não precisa dele porque ele não te faz
bem á em relação por exemplo aquelas
amigas que vão para a pizzaria e como em
toda a pizzaria e continuam magras
aquelas que a gente tem vontade de matar
eu tenho
juro que eu tenho que eu não posso comer
mais que duas fatias daquela bem fininha
que parece uma hóstia integral ainda com
um pouquinho de frango porque se tiver
aquele que jogou do gostoso maravilhoso
no dia seguinte pode ter certeza vou ter
que correr pelo menos seis quilômetros
pra me segurar porque essa amiga
desgraçado é máquina
porque o dna dela é bom e alguns de nós
nem todos temos urgência a obesidade o
nome dele ft o hoje em junho que a gente
queria deixar pra lá
na verdade bom em relação aos custos
desse exame
o exame como toda tecnologia nova por
exemplo um iphone 6 plus
ele não tá barato na verdade então os
valores ainda não são tão acessíveis são
para alguns mas eu espero que no futuro
isso seja um pouquinho mais acessível
como por exemplo no passado o exame de
sangue era muito caro hoje se tornou uma
coisa rotineira e em se falando em exame
de sangue ele é o que a ponta do iceberg
da nossa saúde
o dna ele a base do iceberg ou seja ele
pode se manifestar ou não e ele já é uma
tendência do mercado tá certo lá nos
estados unidos os americanos já as
pessoas já chegam e já dosam hoje em
existem vários casos no consultório de
um paciente que já ia operar o coração e
no exame é na verdade eu não vou mentir
na época eu sou uma pessoa bem
transparente ele não tinha ainda feito
exame de dna mas foi se tratá la em nova
é ok e lá em nova york eles detectaram
já um gent se chama mph fr
esse gênio ele detecta a carência ou
absorção de vitaminas do complexo b
principalmente a de 9 que em homens ele
pode trazer taquicardia dias e ele tinha
esse déficit o médico lá em nova york
fez a suplementação e ele não precisou
fazer uma cirurgia cardíaca série cima e
isso é uma coisa muito boa na verdade
mulheres que têm a carência nesse gmt
hfr podem abortar várias vezes porque
porque traz carência do ácido fólico
então é importante demais parece
brincadeira mas é um pontinho que entre
a vida ea não vida existe um pesquisador
em harvard que aquelas coisas do acaso é
que eu digo que nada nessa vida por
acaso que você não está aqui hoje por
acaso que eu não tô aqui hoje por acaso
eu chegando em casa cansada estava
ligado lá na globo news que meu marido
ama escutar globonews e tinha um médico
sendo entrevistado esse médico em
harvard ele é um oncologista e ele
estava contando duas histórias uma
paciente dele tinha um câncer na ponta
do nariz e ela em três meses faleceu
já um outro paciente dele é um senhor
que tem um câncer na boca do estômago é
um câncer super mega agressivo quem é
médico aqui sabe o quanto é agressivo um
câncer na boca do estômago
só que ele está vivo há dez anos porque
porque ele é o único responsável de duas
crianças cuja esposa faleceu no quarto
ele não pode morrer então ele tem que se
ligar vida de um jeito sobrenatural
eles já fez 10 que meus terapias e ele
sai melhor de cada quimioterapia
para quem pensa que a nutrição é apenas
um bem estar e uma barriga tanquinho a
nutrição e saúde
e eu quero te convidar a raciocinar que
só existem duas coisas que podem alterar
a manifestação do seu genro
a primeira coisa é a alimentação que
você está colocando para dentro do seu
corpo eu lhe pergunto você abastece o
seu carro com gasolina ruim você coloca
aditivos e olhos que não são autorizados
pela autorizada e porque hoje você está
como colocando qualquer coisa pra dentro
do seu corpo
eu te leva a pensar que o pensamento é a
segunda coisa que mais interferem uma na
manifestação genética como caso dessas
duas pessoas uma que se entregou e o
outro que não entrega a vida nem pelo
amor de deus eu convido você a
raciocinar que a dieta hoje de
batata-doce franguinho de ovo ela não é
pra qualquer um pode não funcionar para
você então s mito do instagram nem
sempre está correto porque você é um ser
único
você tem uma digital você é um ser
especial
tá certo que o alimento ele vai trazer
vida e não morte e uma última colocação
a nutrição hoje está sendo colocada no
instagram como simples objeto de prazer
ou como barriga bonita como corpos
sarados
ela é muito mais do que isso ela é um
bem estar
ela é criatividade ela é exemplo que
você pode dar os seus filhos pra você
mesmo para a sociedade e para as pessoas
que te cercam em volta porque nada
melhor do que você está perto de uma
pessoa que exala saúde felicidade
bem-estar ela contagia
eu convido já pensar que pensamentos
você tem hoje a respeito
você mesmo você se olha no espelho e diz
assim eu sou feio tô moroso e gorduras e
eu tenho não sei que aceite se do jeito
que você é o que você é especial
você é sim bonito porque você como nosso
amigo poeta disse quem nega sua origem
não pode aceitar mais nada dessa vida
então vamos aceitar quadris largos ou
pernas grossas ou finas e sermos felizes
e mais uma coisa o que você está fazendo
hoje a contagiar a você mesmo de saúde
de felicidade de bem-estar de
espiritualidade não só de um corpo
sarado
muito obrigado